l'année dernière roanne plust lancer une
nouvelle gamme de smartphones c'était le
one + nord dont on a connu en bonne
place avec un flagship sa déclinaison
avec un mode lte est un peu plus tard
dans l'année
il ya eu ensuite un modèle professionnel
gamme north qui arrivait gamme plus
accessible et là il ya un autre modèle
de cette gamme nord qui vient d'arriver
c'est le one plus'' noord cee singer
[Musique]
qu'est-ce qu'on a là dedans
comment ça sauve des instrus comme ça ça
ah ok super packaging jours les médias
keeps hausse assez marrant ça c'est
super rigolo j'aime bien ça change on
ensuite quoi la boîte du smartphone qui
est juste là alors on va bien ces deux
gammes noord pas grand chose de plus là
dessus je suis fort nous igad ram 256 go
de stockage couleurs blue boys on se
regarde ça dans quelques instants
qu'est ce qu'on a on a même une petite
coque ici à l'intérieur c'est sympa avec
ce côté qui va vous indiquez le nord on
a quoi ici petit livre est ok avec
quelques petits infos là dedans et on
retrouve à l'intérieur un bloc de
charges c'est la vap charge 30 watts et
puis leur fameux câbles rougeole de la
recharge en usb c'est bon rien de
surprenant dans la boîte ça fonctionne
ce qui m'intéresse c'est de voir à quoi
ressemble cette jolie petite bête ça
souffle comme ça c'est pas mal hein
c'est de couleurs comme ça triple caméra
avec un 64 mégapixels ou qui est prise
en main classique c'est très drôle je
sais pas si vous le voyez bien j'ai des
reflets là je suis sur une espèce de de
turquoise un peu vert et là j'ai
vraiment ou du bleu sur le côté tout un
contour bleus avec un côté violine qui
se prononce vraiment sur le violine
lorsque je suis à l'extérieur là je sais
pas si vous le voyez bien dit que le
mans commentaires c'est vraiment super
super chouette j'aime beaucoup alors
quel que soit l'endroit où je me
positionne n'a jamais vraiment son côté
j'ai vraiment le côté bleu violine là
ici son côté dans sa marche bien ti
micro pour la réduction brute sur le
côté ici j'ai courage et tiroirs de
cartes sim bouton de volume prise jack
ou qui est très bien le micro la
recharge le haut parleur et puis si j'ai
le bouton pour l'allumer pour l'éteindre
alors ici à la différence des autres
modèles de windows j'ai pas de petit
switch pour venir mettre en sonnerie
silencieux
et vibreurs mais sinon comme il est là
il est plutôt sympa donc ça me plaît
avant de vous donner mon retour sans se
produit on va déjà parler un peu des
specs et voir ce qu'il a dans le ventre
alors un truc qui est intéressant ici
c'est que vous avez un écran fluide
amoled technology ltt hausse et du full
hd + un taux de rafraîchissement de 90
hier une diagonale de 6,43 pouces et un
ratio vingt neuvième
ça se tient rien de surprenant rien de
des conneries au niveau audio vous avez
du bluetooth 5.1 compatible à péter x hd
à ptx hell d'ac mais également assez et
en plus vous l'avez vu je voulais
montrer lorsqu'on l'a ouverte mais s'il
ouvert il ya quelques jours donc là j'ai
eu le temps de m'amuser un petit peu
avec et bien vous avez une prise jack
intéressant côté performances on tombe
sur un dragon 750 g pour gaming un
processeur 5 g avec le modem il 52 de
qualcomm ici on a chez qualcomm foule
qualcomm et ça marche bien et on a même
une adreno 619 voile comme une fois de
plus côté stockage vous avez 68 soit 256
go de stockage chez lui fs 2.1 non
extensible et côté ram vous avez 6 8 ou
12 giga de ram en épée ddr4 x une fois
de plus un grand classique vous avez une
grosse batterie de 4500 emilie amp
erreurs ici et ici pas de recharge sans
fil quand filaire l'expérience logiciel
c'est oxygène os on se basait sur un
android 11 août à tous un grand
classique et ça marche très très bien
pointé super intéressant aussi sur la
partie logicielle c'est que vous avez
deux ans assurés de mise à jour one
pluzz deux ans assure est de mise à jour
software pour basculer sur les dernières
versions d'oxygène o s et bien
évidemment d'android donc assez cool et
trois ans oui trois ans de mise à jour
de sécurité à narnia vous avez trois
capteurs alors ici forcément sans doute
rares va pas faire un gros focus sur la
photo comme on a pu le voir sur le wan
plus'' 9 et le neuf pros on n'est pas
ici sur des capteurs on travaille pas
ici avec un seul blake s'est pas du tout
l'idée ici par contre vous avez un
grand-angle de 64 mégapixels qui ouvre à
f 1.79 pas de stabilisation optique
uniquement une stabilisation
électronique vous avez un ultra
grand-angle de 8 mégapixels qui ouvre à
f 2.25 sont 19 degrés au niveau du champ
de vision stabilisation électronique
également pas d'optique du tout et puis
après vous avez un capteur monochrome a4
monochrome de 2 mégapixels touvre f 2.4
et à la vente dans une caméra selphy de
16 mégapixels
tu ouvres f 2.4 on se regarde le
résultat bien évidemment dans quelques
instants
et vous pouvez voir la vidéo jusqu'en
4,4 en images par seconde on a du nfc
pour le paiement dématérialisé puis on à
double carte sim au niveau tarif sait
tous ici ne sait pas forcément appris
par coeur au niveau tarif des plusieurs
config 628 à 299 euros extrêmement bien
placé vous avez uniquement la couleur
chakwal inc ils vont nous annoncer c'est
un gris a priori vous avez une version
828 à 329 euros en rajoute un petit peu
d'argent mais ça peut valoir le coup on
a le blues void couleurs que j'ai
notamment ici qui est vachement bien et
vous avez également le shark à chakwal
inc compliqué les noms chez one peut
être penser à revoir la copie c'est très
compliqué on trouve peut-être le
traduire je sais pas et vous avez une
version 12 + 2 156 à 399 euros dans les
mêmes couleurs le bleu et le gris voilà
et s'il vous intéresse vous amis tous
les liens en bas dans la description
verdict sur son nouveau one plust normes
cee 5 g ça vient compliquer les noms
sadia très compliqué alors écoutez moi
y'a quelques points que j'aime bien
qu'elles seront vraiment intéressant il
s'inscrit dans cette gamme de
smartphones qu'on va retrouver aux
alentours de 299 euros à 399 euros
si les critiques sont là les gentils
sèche on est vraiment dans cette idée là
dans cette gamme de prix dont on va pas
s'attendre à voir des trucs complètement
dingos d'agde où il ya une très grosse
offre il ya beaucoup de noms il ya
beaucoup de concurrence dans cette gamme
de prix
moi ce que je vais bien aimé ici déjà
c'est le dos alors on retrouve un design
signé ou en place ici rien de bien
surprenant au niveau du design du
smartphone je vais bien aimé néanmoins
ses couleurs au niveau du dos deuxième
gros point positif ici c'est la dalle on
a une très belle dalle fluide un mollet
d'une dalle signé samsung qui marche
bien taux de rafraîchissement de 90 et
ça marche bien que c'est ce qu'on attend
aussi des smartphones dans cette gamme
de prix
donc rien de bien surprenant mais ça va
et ça fonctionne bien elle est bien
calibré donc ça c'est pareil en gros
point positif donc pour tout ce qui m
visionnage série navigation sur les
différents réseaux sociaux et bien on a
une dalle de qualité donc ça une fois de
plus gros pouce bleus il ya une config
qui va surtout m'intéresser pour moi le
bon prix sur ce produit à ça avec le 828
à 329 euros parce qu'un peu plus de
fluidité grâce à la rame d'un stockage
de 128 giga de stockage sun va bien on
peut mettre plein de choses dans le
coeur de jorion pourquoi pas alors
n'oubliez pas ici qui n'est pas
extensible mais cette config là elle me
paraîtra bien vous avez quand même 30
euros d'écart entre le 628 et le 828
donc partait sur le 828 le processeur
sera suffisamment puissante quand on est
plein de jeunes aux crânes bien des
colons ici il ya toujours cette gamme de
prix c'est très cohérent et autre chose
que je vais vraiment beaucoup aimé c'est
toute l'expérience logiciel avec oxygène
os 11 mars sur l'android 11 et toutes
les mises à jour vous avez derrière mise
à jour 2 ans
d'os et trois ans de sécurité donc ça
c'est bien c'est extrêmement rassurant
et pour le consommateur c'est une bonne
expérience et ça ça me plaît beaucoup
donc là c'est vachement bien
et puis ce dernier point qui va
m'intéresser si c'est la vache charge 30
sa recharge rapidement quand vous
commencez à manquer un peu de batterie
vous le branchez vous le charger
rapidement il ya un côté très rassurant
alors on va pas aller aussi loin que ce
qu'on peut retrouver sur les one + 9 et
one + 9 procès normal mais par contre ce
qu'on a ici est bien vu positionnement
tarifaire ça marche bien on n'est pas
écrit sur un smartphone qui est optimisé
pour la photo néanmoins on a trois
capteurs on va regarder ce que ça dit
laurent laubry sur le capteur principal
c'est pas mal dans l'ensemble c'est pas
mal je vais trouver ça un peu moins
saturé que ce qu'on peut retrouver
lorsqu'on y regarder la scène avec ses
propres yeux
et lorsque vous précis sur l'ultra grand
tante par contre là c'est sûr saturé
c'est dingue ou regarder la différence
au niveau du ciel et vous récupérez
beaucoup de bouille ici donc l'ultra
grand temps il n'est pas dingue dingue
oh c'est pas précis s'ébruiter c'est
trop saturé c'est pas d'accord on peut
se rapprocher en x 2 un peu mais pas
plus x 5 c'est pas terrible il faut
disent c'est pas beau du tout non une
fois de plus dans cette gamme de prix
c'est normal on continue ici voyez les
détails sont quand même assez correct on
voit que c'est un poil tram est ici au
niveau des hautes lumières sur le les
nuages de plus ultra grand-angle c'est
pas dingue trop saturé la caméra de
celle fille fera le boulot c'est pas un
truc de dingue mais on n'est pas non
plus sur un photophone on n'est pas sur
un envoi de place neuve donc on sait je
vous montre quelques photos voyez bon et
c'est pour moi c'est l'ultra grand-angle
il vraiment souvent c'est vraiment le
truc est pas terrible la caméra
principale conviendra mais l'ultra grand
temps que c'est pas beau c'est trop
saturé voilà c'est vraiment ce qu'il
faut venir tenir ici alors j'ai pas fait
de photos de nuit parce que c'est pas un
smartphone qui est armé pour faire de la
photo de nu et vous voyez si ce qu'on
préfère principalement les usages
principaux c'est à dire votre grand
angle normal au delà de ça c'est pas
dingue grand-angle x 2 et tout le reste
on oublie parce qu'on n'aura pas des
photos de qualité
il ya des points qui sont un peu en
dessous l'audio avec un haut parleur
mono c'est pas fou fou mais une fois de
plus dans cette gamme de prix c'est ce
qu'on s'attend à retrouver donc rien de
bien surprenant
il est équilibré il est bien il est bon
il est un peu en dessous en photo mais
une fois de plus ont remis en
perspective par rapport au prix par
rapport à toutes les offres pour trouver
sur le marché
donc ça innove qui est intéressant si
vous aimez onepoll si vous aimez oxygène
eau s est bien ici vous avez un
smartphone qui est très honnête qui est
très sympa qui en 5 g a pour moi le bon
prix c'est 329 euros
voilà tout ce que j'avais à vous dire
aujourd'hui sur ce smartphone wyplosz
nord de 5g le nom sorin allonge les noms
se rallongent et surtout avec la 5g
alors quand on sera plus dans l'univers
5g quand la 5g sera passée on aura
dénoncer on aura des noms un peu
standard un peu plus court on serait sûr
un one plus forte c'est le why not
pourquoi pas donc ça c'est plutôt
intéressant
la proposition de loi ne pleuve ici est
intéressante à vous oui oui vous de me
dire ce que vous en pensez
on va juste en bas ici dans les
commentaires est ce que ça vous plaît
est ce que vous êtes déjà client chez
one pleuvent c'est ce que voulait être
sur le haut de gamme est ce que soit la
gamme north ça pourrait vous tentez ce
que vous avez déjà un smartphone plus
games d'anvers moment la guerre de l'eau
parce qu'il est récent forcément c'est
une gamme qui est récente et dites moi
si vous pourriez succomber s'il vous
plaît
point négatif pour vous qui vous
bloquerez à l'achat ou point positif
également marqué moi tout ça en garde ça
bien évidemment ensemble dans les
commentaires huit mois vous naissez
parce que là ils sortent on bronze un
petit peu il fait beau il fait une
chaleur incroyable
ça y est la bonne météo est arrivé le
beau temps est là ça c'est vachement
bien donc l'été arrive et on va pouvoir
boire des mojitos tranquillement en
terrasse avec des amis sans plaisir
voilà vous embrasse des bellons pour les
soins de vous offrir à très vite ciao